and if you
supersede that constant need for
gratification
if you supersede that constant need for
kindness
you suddenly know you who you are and
what i like to say to my kid and my son
the other day was telling me oh
so-and-so called me such and such and
i'm like are you such and such
he's like no i'm like ha ha see they
were wrong
and what i tell him is if you know who
you are
what other people say about you only
teaches you
about them yeah
so it has no influence on your
self-esteem
if you know where you stand you embrace
the good but you also embrace the bad
i have plenty of bad and i'm embracing
it
i'm a procrastinator how do i deal with
that
i trick myself into procrastinating
about mindless stupid little
day-to-day things and in that
procrastination time doing important
things for the future
so accepting who you are accepting your
flaws accepting the whole of it
accepting the struggle accepting the
sleeplessness
accepting the fact that the journey is
what matters
hoping that your path to ithaca is full
of troubles
because those troubles are the life you
will lead
accepting that life will not start
after the next milestone that life has
already started a long time ago
and what you're experiencing now is the
life
this is it it's not some kind of future
thing that you worked yourself hard to
get to
and then after that you live happy
happily ever after
to me the happily ever after that's the
end of the story nothing happens after
that
they struggled in the struggle and the
struggle is much more interesting story
than they lived happily ever after so i
think we have to embrace that as a as a
society that it's not just about the
happy ending that our kids
are brainwashed into expecting that
things will be happy and rosy
and it's okay if they're not and they
should keep struggling because the
struggle
is the journey and the journey is the
meaning of life
it's not the end it's the journey
you